I'm just saying I've never seen one up
close okay why don't you let us know in
the youtube community section if you
think bald eagles are real see you next
time on every damn day guys
great show great show Ryan little less
nose next time ah just a quick note
everybody research says that our show is
in dire need of a bad boy type that's
right
so you're each gonna give a little
presentation for the suits unless one of
you can prove that you're the bad boy we
might have to look into other options as
in replace you because you're not good
at your job okay
good show
[Music]
Hanna why don't you start us off this is
so stupid why are we even doing this I'm
clearly the baddest state your case then
I show up whenever I want
I wear a leather jacket I put four loko
in all of the couch cushions and I've
been replacing Ryan's coffee with dip
spit for weeks the viewers don't believe
you're a bad boy material why cuz I'm a
woman
yes our research shows that our audience
hates women and want to make Comedy
Central great again that means bad boys
and saying the phrase I'm Rick James but
this is
no it's not it's backed by data are you
getting your coffee don't be such a
little bit I believe I misunderstood the
assignment so who ate my pasta salad me
Oh excellent
no further questions your honor shaving
it bald and returning it before they've
noticed item 14 adult circumcision item
15 we've seen enough what about the time
I started the trash fire in the office
yeah and because of that name tag Terri
got promoted to safety officer thanks
Hannah
yeah hi name Terry
[Music]
any pasta salad left one part macaroni
three parts worms
okay Ryan your last step this is
ridiculous
state your case I have no case I'm not
the bad boy I don't want to be the bad
boy I just want to make a good show okay
we feel that you're all pretty bad like
bad bad bad so we're just gonna go with
Ryan for any bad boy stuff because he's
easiest to bully come on don't complain
okay this says a lot of talent in this
room the macaroni is worms okay we asked
you what we should tattoo on Ryan's neck
and you voted for Selina let's see how
it's going
[Music]
you